buddy mindful way back in the day then
with the SPN since 1993 and has been
associated with the sport of baseball
for almost every single one of those
years call ravage back on the show how
are you Carl I'm good I'm celebrating
the fact that they have just opened up a
brand-new Dunkin Donuts drive-through on
Cottage Grove Road which goes from the
airport back home to where I live so I'm
kind of in a good mood about that today
there was do they still have the Kenny
Rogers rollin roaster that Kilbourne
took me through after my third
SportsCenter and southington Carl is
that still there that's tiller
you know Queen Street which is the home
to every single food entities on the
planet actually not just in the country
frequented over Queen Street lately okay
Carl like you I'm not in the studio very
often anymore
that's right I know you were doing such
a great job describing my michigan
wolverines going down in the College
World Series you were very gentle on
that one you did a great job doing that
and it's obviously so much more than you
know what I'll take it now when the
Commissioner called the commissioners
trophy a hunk of metal did you do one of
those moments sitting in your chair when
that happened Carl or was that something
just later on it kind of dawned on
everybody that he referred to it is that
I think later on it kind of dawned on
everybody and there were only a handful
of instances where he was something that
I would I would have that we'll wait a
minute that can't be right or are you
sure about that
so the hunk of metal probably slid by
without be paying too much attention to
it and I probably to some degree
understood at that point the sort of
rhetorical part of what he was saying he
was he was making a point as he
acknowledged later in in a poor way that
if I just take away the trophy whether
it's a piece of metal or it's you know
24 karat gold that's that to me is less
symbolic than then the punishment that i
issue which is to you know in a sense
hester prynne this entire organization
and they'll be walking around with that
Scarlet Letter for the rest of their
lives so I think they
kind of our anyway though and that's the
I mean every single time you take a look
at what's going on from an angle then it
twists in in a way that that's
uncontrollable by baseball and the twist
that I honestly didn't see coming was
the full throated angry full throated
issues that the rest of the players in
Major League Baseball are taking call is
is this surprising to you in any way
shape or form I think you know the title
wins I mean it started to gather steam
and then you start to throw the biggest
names in the game on there and you've
got the West Coast covered with
Bellinger and trout you got the East
Coast covered with all the Yankees and
everyone in between yeah I look I don't
think we've ever experienced even with
performance enhancers I mean remember
when we were in the whole steroid era
that really reduced itself to the people
that used and then those that were so
quiet they didn't say anything in this
case everyone is saying something about
it and it's uniformly sort of manifested
in the fact that they don't believe and
I think it's moving towards this forget
the fact that they weren't punished as
individuals I I get the sense that many
players are beginning to understand with
the immunity etc etc that that's going
to happen but the idea that they were
cheated I mean look you me Aaron judge
whoever it is have played competitively
at some level and you recognize when
someone is cheating the the playing
field is not level and that infuriates
you and now instead of what we used to
do you know on our own fields these guys
are doing it for millions of dollars
they're doing it for legacy they're
doing it to be World Series champions
which does in the long run carry a great
deal of cachet when you're out speaking
when you're trying to get into the Hall
of Fame and somebody cheated them out of
that and it's not surprising that it's
the best players in the game who are who
are in that realm of MVP awards series
given the teams that we've heard most of
these players talk from so those are
legacy things and somebody cheated them
out of it so I understand the venom and
I understand the anger Carl rabbits
on the Rich Eisen show I'm saying it's
time for the the Commissioner's Office
to release you know all all the evidence
that they've gotten like literally it
interviews every single piece of
evidence that they have received I guess
to use the the the Muller report
phrasing I guess the 302s that the FBI
is had with with all the interviewees
like I want to see the hard raw evidence
here because the commissioners saying
that this stuff was used in the 2017
postseason the Astros have said that
they didn't and I understand that the
players received immunity there's no
reason why they received they should
receive anonymity unless the immune
recovers that and if if the evidence
shows it was used in the first round but
not the World Series
shouldn't that tamp down anything coming
from Los Angeles and New York I mean
it's time to to put all that in front of
the fans I wonder what you think of that
Karl no I think that makes sense I think
that the stripping of a title makes a
great deal of sense I agree with the the
immunity at least in my world and I'm
not a labor lawyer and on a lot of
levels you got to remember that Rob
Masters background is literally in labor
law this is a harvard-educated guy he
understands the minutiae of the law he
knew in his opinion that if if he went
to file grievances he would get hammered
by the Players Association and this is
such a litigious history to this sport
most people understand when it comes to
the CBA
you know the owners are going to win
they always do when it comes to
collusion oh we got to stay away from
that because the players are going to
win he believes that if we try to go
after these players publicly or or got
into a grievance situation because they
weren't informed of the situation but
that they were going to get hammered so
he chose to go the other way yes a
hundred percent I think we should I
think we would head in that direction
given given that the forest fires have
now become infernos and you can see the
Players Association this is a very
delicate line that these guys are both
walking here because they both I think
stand a great deal to lose you know Tony
Clark with the Players Association
Manfred is the commissioner I think they
wrote recognize they probably need each
other more than they want to fight
against each other because this is going
to blow up in a way that I don't think
they had anticipated and it already has
so sure I think that he probably has has
let everyone know in the in the know we
could just release all the transcripts
as well which is you know a term we've
been used to hearing but short of that I
don't understand rich the idea that he's
worried about Pandora's Box being open
personally I think it's an it's an easy
one to say look the players have given
me sort of carte blanche here to go
punish other players they're asking me
to rescind the World Series trophy you
know after a great deal of internal
conversation between my own self and
Hall of Famers and certainly the
majority of players if not unanimous
amongst the players I decided that we
will take away and vacate the 2017 World
Series title so it's not really my
decision
I'm acquiescing to the wishes of
everybody who didn't wear an astro
uniform but the issue is on that is what
about the you know the Verlander's of
the world right i mean it's pitching and
defense - it's not just hitting right i
mean yeah but you know to me III would
in my case be able to consciously be
comfortable with drawing the line
between anybody that wore the uniform
because because just by adding more runs
to a Verlander start he benefited from
it it just strikes me is your reaction
right there rich is exactly what these
guys are dealing with I promise you that
that interview which you know he did at
7:00 a.m. and lasted 45 minutes he
looked just like that like oh gosh I
just I didn't anticipate this we're
trying to clean the game up I mean at
its core are they trying to do something
that would improve the game yes we're
trying to get signed stealing and
electronic sign stealing out of the game
it's illegal we don't want to allow it
at its core this is a fundamentally
smart step to take but just your
exasperation is exactly what he's
dealing with the players are dealing
with and you can hear the same way you
and I did years ago at ESPN doing
SportsCenter during the McGwire socha
era right people get so tired of it and
we're four or five days in and you can
tell they're getting tired of it call
Robert you're in the Rich Eisen show
yeah I guess the difference is from the
steroid era and this era of this style
of cheating is that the it's the
ultimate performance enhancer of knowing
if a pitch is coming and then you use
technology like this and the question is
is what is the pound of flesh it really
is the trophy I mean that is is that is
that what you don't really tamp it down
right yeah I think it is because I I
just don't think that they are overly
concerned to me these guys seem more
worried about the fact that they won
like again just go back to the basic
tenets of competition the playing field
is supposed to be level and these guys
turned it a hundred and eighty degrees
on level as Trout has said as Jess
Stanton said today if I knew what pitch
was coming Rich Eisen would be
celebrating Yankee home runs on the west
coast 80 times a year off my bat you
know whether that's exaggerated or not
it doesn't matter the point is we were
supposed to be playing on a level
playing field
understanding the gray area that always
exists when it comes to level playing
field in Major League Baseball however
in this case this is one where every
team seemed to know the line in the sand
is a red line and you can't cross it and
not only did they cross it you know they
they napalmed it as somebody once said
hmm Carl rabbits here a few more minutes
left from ESPN on the Rich Eisen show so
what's next
obviously the Red Sox report from the
2018 season is still to come and
baseball is just trying to get to
opening day man just trying to get where
where where where baseball's being
played and the sports up and running and
perhaps we're all distracted
unless of course Altuve has a too
a batting 250 Baker's got this team 40
and 10 and they're on a you know what
tour so it's not really going away what
it walked me through the next steps here
that baseball has planned or might pop
up well the two the two sides are
working together on coming up with
uniform rules about signs dealings which
to my understanding will include player
punishments hmm so the me sort of you
know flesh that they're talking about
are you referred to moving forward there
we're there will be flesh I think
they've landed at a place
the Commissioner has unless this
continues to spiral out of control and
he reverses course and says to your
opponent to others you know what screw
it I am going after the players because
I've been made to look so bad Here I am
going to now go after the players and I
will figure out a way that the contract
conduct that they were doing was
detrimental to the game there's some
clause which allows me to punish people
who behave in a way that's detrimental
to the game and clearly this is one of
those he could go you know he could go
rogue and say forget it my back's up
against the wall I'm pushing back I
think what's going to happen though is
you're going to have new bylaws that
will have discipline for players they'll
be significant I think there will be new
bylaws about batters getting hit by
pitches I think they will do their level
best both sides to remove the use of
video I mean you'd appreciate it you
know this point was when Rich Eisen
walks off the 6th green he doesn't go to
a 10th to look at a swing before he hits
his tee shot on 7 and says oh I can see
that I know my weight was was back on my
back foot you don't have that in many
sports if any sports and they're going
to outlaw that as well I think the Red
Sox investigation yields less of the
Astros does I think he has Corey in his
crosshairs anyway and he's going to get
us too significant a punishment as hitch
did if not a little bit worse because he
was probably at least that we've been
told kind of a bad actor in all this the
guy that that helped bring it to the
players who then utilized it and I think
once spring training game start you
reckon
that the 29 other fan bases and the
players will turn their attention the
same way Kirsch I did yesterday say you
know what it will there be any greater
motivation to destroy the Astros on the
field and what they just did in the past
and I think it's gonna be real difficult
for that team to perform given the
circumstances they're gonna deal with
everywhere they go well I appreciate the
analogy to my golf game Carl but you
know going to the seventh tee I'll
probably be at some comfort station cuz
I don't put nearly as much into the game
as you as you have for your game what's
what's your golf game looking like now
are you are you giving strokes to the
course Carl I be honest with you since
you and I know each other it it's kind
of it's just leveled off I've I've never
been able to get into the plus category
probably a four or five right now and
it's it's just there and I just rate
respect for all your buddies on the tour
there are you know plus seven right
Brooks cap goes of the world I don't
know how they do that I I don't have the
time to dedicate to it because well
you're on comfort station yes some
flying to Baton Rouge or to a good cup
of Dunkin Donuts cough so this does uh
does bucho grass have the best dick at
ESPN still is he still a guy I would
love to you know you if you ever want to
put together a Rich Eisen annual
tournament Butchie and I should play
each other it's rare that we do although
we have talked about it and we did play
once I think in the last couple of years
and and I'm not playing naive I you know
he may have won by one or two I may have
I I totally forget the school I really
do
you're the best Carl thanks for the call
appreciate it
thank you bet back at you that's call
right for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app